on se serait pas réveillé en même temps
dis toi que j'y ai énormément réfléchi
New York c'est l'endroit où vivent les
vrais écrivains et je commence à penser
peut-être que je suis un vrai écrivain
moi aussi quoi tu me l'as pas dit ne lui
dis rien c'est bien attention
garde-le pour toi
c'est juste que j'entends toutes ces
voix dans ma tête tout le temps et ben
voilà
joli pantalon merci
enfin
c'est vrai qu'il a toute une histoire ce
pantalon
je sais exactement ce que vous allez
dire j'allais rien dire du tout profite
juste de la vue tu n'as pas besoin
d'aide ta mère est là vous êtes vraiment
flippant
[Musique]
je suis venu à New York et pour me
concentrer sur moi et ma carrière
d'écrivain tu n'as aucune raison de par
ça et c'est ça fêter la raison c'est
marrant le diable est en fait une carte
très mal comprise
tu as toujours voulu être romancien j'ai
toujours su que j'avais des choses
importantes à dire mais je redoutais que
personne ne veuille les entendre elle
t'aime pas elle pense juste que tes
riches n'écoutes pas tu es le meilleur
mon pote
tout le monde ce qui me disait qui je
devais être qu'est-ce que tu fous c'est
différent avec Lindsay parce qu'elle est
spéciale ça c'est en fait non c'est
gentil il est temps de rentrer gentiment
à la maison dans cette ville tu as été
percutée par trois taxis quand même qui
ne roulait pas si vite que ça
c'est toi envahissent son esprit et lui
dise non surtout les tons et ne voit pas
ce que je vois
elle ne t'apprécie pas à ta juste valeur
elle ne te mérite pas
ce n'est pas de ta vie dont tu parles
c'est de la mienne ça me rend malade que
tout le monde me dise comment je dois me
comporter
j'ai trouvé ma propre histoire
ça va aller ouais je vais gérer
[Musique]